this video is a 3d protein viewing
experience to view this properly you're
going to need a VR headset or Google
cardboard or something like that if you
don't have that there's also a version
of this video that's not in 3d for you
to enjoy but the best way to view this
is in 3d so if you're ready let's strap
on your VR headset and let's begin what
you're looking at right now is a protein
turning slowly in three-dimensional
space this rotation is artificial I'm
doing this so that you can see the whole
protein but this is an actual 3d
structure of a real protein scientists
can crystallize proteins and then shoot
the crystal with x-rays the direction
that the X rays bounce off is used to
determine the actual 3d structure so
although individual proteins are too
small to be seen we can use the x-ray
crystallography data to view them
scientists can view the same protein in
different ways and we use computer
programs to make models or renderings
depending on the important information
we want to convey about the structure in
this video I want to introduce you to
the basics of molecular visualization so
that you can begin to understand what
you're even looking at when you see a
picture of a protein in a textbook or if
your instructor wants you to look at a
protein using one of these modeling
programs and I figured out how to show
this to you in 3d without expensive
glasses or having to cross your eyes at
a printed magic eye style picture until
the protein popped out at you seriously
this is how we used to have to do this
and it always gave me a terrible
headache you should have a basic
understanding of the levels of protein
structure before watching this video we
need to start with something small so
we're going to look at the amino acid
alanine first notice the color coding
this is called CPK coloring and it tells
us which atoms were looking at nitrogen
is always blue and oxygen is red take a
good look at the red atoms
the program that I'm using shows a
double line to show the double bond to
the carbonyl of the amino acid carboxyl
group this structure is not shown at
biological pH notice there is a white
colored hydrogen atom on the other
oxygen amino acids ionize inform
zwitterions in the body so that hydrogen
atom would be on the amine group at
biological pH but typically we show the
proteins without any of the H atoms
anyway because they clutter up the image
too much so you need to remember your
rules for valence and ionization when
viewing this stick rendering of the
protein structure since you won't see
any of the hydrogen atoms here I've
arbitrarily colored carbon green but we
can choose any color for carbon however
it is unwise to color the carbon atoms
dark blue or red since you'll lose
structural information sulfur is another
element found in amino acids like
methionine here and it's CPK color is
yellow so you probably want to avoid
that color for backbone carbon atoms as
well before we move on let's look at
alanine once more see how when nitrogen
is on the Left the sidechain Group
points backward and when the carboxylate
is on the left it points forward this is
because of the stereochemistry of that
carbon atom most amino acids are chiral
compounds and only one of the
enantiomers is found in human proteins
this plays a big role in the 3d
structure of the protein and determines
which molecules the protein will
interact with remember individual amino
acids link up in long chains to create
the secondary structure of a protein
here we're looking at a tripeptide made
up of cysteine valine and lysine notice
the nitrogen is next to a carbonyl now
we get an amat or peptide bond when the
amino acids link up this isn't too bad
to look at but things get a little crazy
once we start viewing this
ten amino acid deca peptide
and it's even worse when we look at an
entire protein rendered as sticks we can
sort of start to see the overall shape
but the image is really cluttered and
confusing we can simplify this a lot
with a rendering called the alpha trace
this makes a line to the peptide bonds
of the protein ignoring side chains the
way that many proteins are rendered for
textbooks and journal articles is the
ribbon diagram though we're losing the
detail of the side chain atoms we're
seeing the overall structure of the
protein very easily along with the alpha
helixes and beta sheets that make up the
secondary structure let's look at this
beta sheet in a little more detail
suppose we want to prove to ourselves
there are strategically located hydrogen
bonds that stabilize this beta sheet and
hold the structure together it's
advantageous to zoom in and show the
stick rendering overlaid on the ribbon
diagram now we can add in the hydrogen
bonds I've colored these dashed lines
yellow notice how they connect blue
nitrogen atoms to red oxygen atoms this
is because the hydrogen atom is not
shown for clarity to understand this
rendering we have to know that the
nitrogen is actually an NH group and
that there's a hydrogen atom making the
H bond to the carbonyl oxygen now let's
take a look at the Alpha helix these
twisting amino acid clusters are also
stabilized by backbone hydrogen bonds
when we show the stick rendering and add
in the yellow hydrogen bonds will notice
they line up differently each carbonyl
group is bonded to an NH of another
backbone atom three to four amino acids
away another very common way to render a
protein is by showing the surface this
traces the outside edge of the protein
notice in some spots on this protein
there are little holes where there are
no amino acid residues and this makes a
gap let's look at an enzyme in the
surface view
here we're looking at hexokinase the
first enzyme involved in the process of
breaking down sugar in your body because
this is an enzyme it catalyzes a
chemical reaction in a region of the
protein called the active site and this
one does so in a deep cleft on the
enzyme can you spot the active site this
crystal structure actually has a
molecule of glucose bound in the active
site let's show that as magenta sticks
and zoom in pretty neat glucose is
sitting there right inside that cleft
it's a little hard to see so let's
change our view of the protein to a
ribbon diagram another way to represent
the glucose molecule is using a sphere
representation kind of like the surface
rendering of the protein this shows the
space that the molecule is taking up
within the enzyme maybe we want to keep
in mind where the surface of the protein
is so let's overlay a see-through mesh
onto the ribbon diagram now we have a
sense of the surface of the enzyme the
secondary structure and we can see the
space that the glucose molecule occupies
awesome I hope you thought this was
super cool and are inspired to look at
some proteins on your own if you are I
put some links in the video description
for you to download the viewing software
I use and then you can peruse more than
a hundred and twenty thousand structures
of proteins and other macromolecules
available in the protein data bank